hey everyone I'm Joe Sasso I'm a chef
here in Los Angeles and I love donuts
I love how fluffy they are how fried
they are how absolutely delicious donuts
are I think you should be able to have
donuts any time of the day in any given
circumstance and you should be able to
have them at home today I'm gonna show
you how to make a 15-minute donut a 50
minute donut and at five hour
donut all right let's get started
picture this you're hanging out with
some friends
you need something sweet you're tired of
brownies you're tired of cake and
cookies but you know what you're never
tired of that's right
donuts first things first we're gonna
make our dredge here for our donuts our
little sugar spice and everything nice
to toss our donuts in after they are
fried I like to start with a little bit
of sugar a little bit of cinnamon a
little bit of salt yes even salt when
you're baking or doing something sweet
and it really just brings out all the
rest of those flavors and then my little
secret twist to this is Szechuan
peppercorn I'm gonna mix this all
together here maybe even use a whisk
make sure it's all combined I'm gonna
set this aside we're gonna use a little
secret doughnut hack we're gonna be
using biscuit dough here there this
start with a little bit of flour just so
we don't have any sticky edge lay out
all of our biscuits this is fun to play
on cronuts which are like croissants fry
it as doughnuts
these are biscuits fried as doughnuts so
they're like doughnuts I'm gonna do the
Miss hold so Bona holds first I'm going
to roll these out about a quarter of an
inch here on the doughnuts I like to
roll them out just a little bit I got a
small hole punch here a ring cutter
because then you have little bone holes
they're cute they're delicious they're
fun small foods are always cuter and
then you have these outer rings you can
bake them as biscuits then you have
biscuit rings you can put an egg in
there you have an egg in the hole we
have our oil here 350 degrees that's
like the magical number when you're
frying things and these are gonna go
pretty fast about three minutes on one
side about a minute or two on the other
drop them all in one by one trying to
get as close to the oil as possible so
there's not a big splash down just kind
of watch the donuts
want to see little bubbles coming off
the side and you're looking for
golden-brown and delicious GBD that's
what we call it in the restaurant it's
been about two minutes here we're gonna
go ahead and flip these guys over
probably got a minute left on this last
side I have my spice mix I have a rack
here to catch my hot donuts the hardest
part is waiting right now but it's only
15 minutes altogether not that bad those
are looking great we're gonna go ahead
and pull them the rack is going to whisk
away any excess oil before we get them
into our sugar spice and everything nice
mix now the trick here donuts still hot
cinnamon sugar right away the donuts are
going to best absorb all of this
goodness while they're hot these guys
will put them back on the rack next for
a little toss toss it smells so good and
there you have it
hot fluffy doughnuts 15 minutes no
thought me what I really love about
these is they're mini doughnuts so you
can eat a lot of them and not feel bad
about it at all make a basket for
yourself share with friends one of my
favorite things about them is the
Szechuan because it adds this little
warming note they're not spicy just a
little hey how you doing let's say you
have a little more time I have a 50
minute doughnut recipe that you should
try next up is a 50 minute doughnut
little non-traditional here we are not
using oil
there is nothing fried everything is
baked in the oven it's a maple bacon
doughnut first thing first we have our
bacon onto a sheet pan
I'm gonna go six slices here we're gonna
pop this bacon in the oven 350 for about
12 to 15 minutes while the bacon is
cooking we're gonna get started on our
donut batter we have three separate
components we have our wet we have our
dry we have our fats I like using cake
flour for this it's very fine it's a
much lighter and delicate crumb we're
gonna sip together our dry ingredients
here
cake flour baking soda baking powder and
a little bit of salt if you don't have a
sifter you can use a whisk combine it
all together in a bowl you're really
just trying to get out all those little
lumps and we're gonna set this aside now
our wet ingredients super easy milk
vanilla together we are going to combine
our fats this we're going to do in two
parts or starting with our
sugar a little bit of softened butter
and a little bit of vegetable oil now
the reason why we're doing this is we're
dispersing all the sugar with the fat
we're aerating it trapping all these
little air pockets in there so that way
when we bake the batter the donuts are
light fluffy and delicious creaming the
butter the sugar and the oil I like to
turn the bowl kind of get in this dual
effect now what we're looking for here
is a lighter color everything becomes
homogeneous and a little light and
fluffy almost like fresh snow I'm gonna
take a spatula here and give my bowl a
nice little scrape down making sure
everything is evenly incorporated now
I'm going to emulsify in my egg again
one more time with the mixer all right
now same thing here fluffy pale in color
smooth homogeneous we'll give it one
more scrape just to make sure we got all
the sugar everything combined the last
step here we're going to add the dry and
the wet alternating starting with the
dry the reason we're doing this is to
not overwork the flour to make sure
there are no lumps and to make sure
everything is beautiful and homogeneous
if we were to overwork this flour
mixture the batter the donuts will come
out dense will come out a little dry
they're not gonna be Airy the crumb
might be a little extra tight this
careful mixing process is gonna all be
worth it in the end I'm gonna add the
last of the milk vanilla stir stir stir
the last of the flour then as soon as
this all comes together and it's
thoroughly combined we're gonna let this
rest only about 15 minutes to ensure
everything is hydrated relaxed and ready
to be baked and in the meantime I'm
gonna check on my bacon bacon here as
you can see crispy golden brown we're
gonna cut this up not looking for a
perfect dice here or just a rough chop
on the bacon of course easy quick simple
no one's judging you here we're gonna
transfer this to a bowl we're ready to
start assembling our Donuts we have
these super fancy schmancy donut pants
here if you don't have these you could
use muffin tins cupcake pans it doesn't
really matter it's just gonna be a
difference
they will still taste perfect and
delicious take some nonstick spray coat
the bottom and then I have my rested
batter and my chopped bacon so about 3/4
of its gonna go down into the pans will
save 1/4 for garnish I'm gonna pour the
batter about 3/4 of the way up it will
rise a little bit in the oven so don't
go too high here measuring cup really
helps with the pouring I like to say
work smarter not harder this is a great
example of that and this batter is
really nice easy to pour I'd say it's
like a little bit of a thin pancake
batter and we have the perfect amount of
batter for 12 little mini donuts I'm
gonna take these off to bake right now
325 for about 15 to 20 minutes while
they're in the oven I'm gonna get
started on my glazed powdered sugar a
little bit of milk a little bit of maple
syrup pinch of salt and we're gonna
whisk this together it's gonna look a
little clumpy at first what you're
looking for here is a nice smooth mix
not too thin we're just gonna run off
the sides of your donuts almost like the
consistency of cold heavy cream like a
nail bit we're gonna set this aside I'm
gonna go check on the donuts donuts are
baked I've let them cool here on a rack
down in the pans I don't want them to
dry out and overcook starting off here
getting my donut into the glaze I'm
gonna dip this in by hand the trick is
to not use hot Donuts you want these
guys to cool down if you're using a hot
donut the glaze is gonna melt really
quickly it's not gonna be a good coating
give it a little wiggle wiggle
dip dip oh baby baby I want all that
excess glaze on there cuz it's yummy
we're going these guys around donut by
donut into the glaze before the glaze
settles on here I want to get a little
bit of topping action some turbinado
sugar it's like a coarse sugar a little
bit of molasses in there for color
that'll add a nice bit of crunch texture
just sprinkle a little bit of that on
top remember that bacon we saved that's
gonna go on top it's great when the
bacon falls into the center then you got
like a little bacon pocket I'm a big fan
of textures bacon
salty sweet all the good things and
there you have it our baked maple bacon
doughnuts I am excited I don't know if
you can tell I can't wait to dive into
it and try these things I'm just gonna
go this one here is calling my name
this is like breakfast and dinner and
doughnuts and everything awesome in the
world all rolled into one so there's no
oil these are not fried technically a
healthier doughnut I mean that's science
now we got these under our belt so you
have a little more time you want to make
something a little extra I have the
ultimate doughnut recipe for you
[Music]
now we have the 5-hour doughnut it's a
little bit more work takes a little bit
more time and commitment but let me tell
you you having a dinner party people are
coming over you want to show them you're
serious about life you're serious about
food this is the doughnut recipe for you
first things first get our dough started
I have all-purpose flour
I have sugar I have salt instant yeast
not active yeast then I have all of my
wet I have eggs
I have buttermilk I have regular milk I
have vanilla I have a lot of things soon
I will have donuts butter melted turning
this on adding my wet ingredients slow
just so everything doesn't fly up in the
bowl low speed till this just comes
together our dough is kneading I'm not
even gonna break a sweat doing this
we're gonna go about four to six minutes
we're really looking for a nice smooth
soft supple dough all right it's been
about five minutes taking a look at the
dough here it's nice and shiny it is a
little sticky it's a wet dough that's
hydrated it's not gonna be a dry
doughnut by any means I have a bowl
sprayed with nonstick I have a spatula
sprayed with nonstick and then that way
is i scrape all of the dough out of the
bowl it doesn't stick to the spatula
either
we're gonna wrap this plastic wrap set
it aside to rest till it's about doubled
in size we're looking at one to two
hours now while this is doing its thing
I'm gonna get to work on my cream
filling this doughnut is filled with a
pastry cream because at the end of the
day what's a doughnut without a cream
filling here we're gonna take milk heat
it up very gently in a large pot not too
fast not too hard you don't want it to
burn while it's milk is heating up we
have some a
we have some sugar some cornstarch
that's gonna help thicken things along
and a pinch of salt and we're just going
to combine this till we have a eggy corn
starchy sugary taste once your milk
comes up to a simmer we're gonna do a
process called tempering tempering is
just a process of introducing something
very hot to something not so very hot if
I were to just take these eggs and add
it right to my milk I would have sweet
milk scrambled eggs which maybe is not
the worst thing in the world but not for
donuts so we'll take a little bit of
milk and two hands here whisking while
slowly drizzling in your milk so now our
eggs are warm we're going to add the
eggs back to the milk mixture continue
to whisk keeping an eye on things making
sure nothing is sticking to the bottom
the cornstarch is gonna thicken egg
yolks are gonna slightly cook and set up
and before you know it you will have
pastry cream take the pot off the heat
softened butter that's gonna help slow
down the cooking process as well keep
things nice and creamy I have a little
bit of vanilla and then our last
ingredient a little bit of lemon juice
it's not gonna be lemony by any means
but a little bit of acid goes a long way
we're going to transfer our mixture
through the strainer and that's really
just to ensure we didn't really cook any
of the eggs all the cornstarch is
equally dispersed we have no lumps press
that through and now while this is
cooling what you're gonna want to do is
take a piece of plastic the plastic is
going to sit on top of the pastry cream
prevent it from forming a skin getting a
weird texture and all that
unpleasantness we're gonna let this cool
to room temperature
we'll add my favorite ingredient rainbow
sprinkles they're fun they're nostalgic
it just makes me happy I feel like you
can never have enough rainbow sprinkles
so we're just gonna fold these little
flakes of joy into the pastry cream my
pastry cream is ready for the donuts I'm
gonna go check on my dough and see how
much it's risen it's been a couple of
hours it's doubled in size and we are
ready to roll and cut it into Donuts
starting with a little bit of flour here
and then I'm going to turn my donut
dough out it's already done one
this is a point where you can take out a
little bit of anger that's gonna punch
out some of that gas and allow it to
rise a second time telling a bit of
flour on top a little bit on my rolling
pin and we're gonna roll this out to
about a half inch thickness we're
looking good I have another ring cutter
a little bigger this time and we're
gonna cut this into donut rounds give it
a little twist so out of this recipe
we're gonna get about six to eight
Donuts
I'll get six nice clean ones here and
then I can Bunch my dough back up
together we roll it out you really only
want to do that once if you do it too
many times your donuts are gonna be a
little dense I'm gonna take a damp
kitchen towel put them to bed
and let them rest till they double in
size again about another one to two
hours and I have one more thing to work
on the final component my frosting
couple of simple ingredients here we
have mascarpone cheese we're gonna go
into a stand mixer with the whisk
attachment and then I have some heavy
whipping cream a little bit of sugar a
little bit of vanilla pinch of salt and
the secret ingredient for this pitaya
pitaya is dried dragon's fruit pink
powder it's a superfood some say it may
turn you into a dragon if you eat it but
tons of vitamins in here I love it as an
alternative to food colorings
and dyes and just whip it together until
soft peaks
nice soft peak all right so my frosting
is all set it's time to go check on
those doughnuts our doughnuts here have
risen doubled in size one last thing
left to do we're going to fry them our
oil here is heated to the magical 350
degree number I'm not gonna crowd my pan
I'll start off with one or two Donuts
here gently lower them into the oil as
to not have them splash and burn myself
or any of my friends around me and you
can see the donuts immediately rise to
the top they start to bubble they're
smelling delicious I can't wait to get
into these I think I could fit one more
donut in here
don't get too close you might burn your
mustache off I'm gonna let these go
about two three minutes or I could see
the bottom starting to get nice and
golden-brown time to give them a flip
and I'm like a little buoys push down on
one side and they'll just float right
over I'm gonna let these go for just
another two or three minutes all right
these look like they're done I'm willing
to pull them out transfer them to the
rack here to cool golden and brown all
around the edges nice and puffy these
three are done here I'm gonna fry off
the rest of them and then it's time to
assemble the time has come I'm excited I
put my pastry cream into a piping bag
fitted with sharp metal tip that's gonna
help with filling these Donuts you're
gonna be able to poke right into the
center and you kind of feel the doughnut
fill up more is good a little bit will
come out at the end and that's how you
know you're full don't worry things get
a little messy we're gonna cover it with
rainbow sprinkles donuts are all full
we'll set this aside and now we're going
to dip into our frosting
I like to get all down swirling in there
and then if there's one thing I always
live by you can never have enough
rainbow sprinkles don't be shy and get
in there get a really really good
coating and onto our landing zone on to
the next one
rainbow sprinkle just make me happy how
could you not me and there you have it
that is an ultimate show-stopping five
our rainbow sprinkle donut and now all
that's left to do all I've been wanting
to do is give these guys a try
moment of truth oh there we are all of
the sprinkles all the frosting I'm gonna
go right in there and sacrifice the
mustache
it's a mouthful of joy that's the best
way to put it you get a little bit of
the easiness from the doughnut that
pastry cream filling loaded with
sprinkles the frosting you get a little
bit of that taste of dragon fruit
there's a nice kind of balance and then
all of the rainbow sprinkles I mean
there's nothing more that I want and
another bite of this this is like the
ultimate bite of your childhood yeah it
is a little bit more hands-on than the
other two recipes but totally worth all
of the work and the ultimate vehicle for
eating donuts and rainbow sprinkles and
there you have it
a doughnut for every occasion the
15-minute doughnut for when you're
craving something sweet in a pinch the
50-minute doughnut for when you don't
feel like getting out that big pot of
fry oil and then the 5 hour impress your
friends blow the socks off of everyone
the ultimate rainbow sprinkle doughnut
let me know what you think in the
comments section below but more
importantly I want you guys to try all
three at home I'm Joe sassed oh and
there's always time for donuts oh yes
[Music]
you
[Music]